it's just inevitable you know you gotta
you gotta roll with you gotta go go with
the flow
um you know it's either you're a shark
or a guppy
you know and i'll be damned if i'm a
guppy so you know
gotta do what you gotta do i grew up in
north hollywood
um it's a
mainly hispanic community um
i grew up in a in a gang infested
neighborhood um
uh just like borderline projects kind of
area
um and uh it's
it's actually very uh back when i was
growing up it was it was it was
dangerous there was a lot of a lot of
killing going on and a lot of drugs you
know
prostitution all on my block and the cop
station was actually on the block as
well
it seems like everything around that the
cop station was the worst and then
everything on the outskirts was
safer but i grew up on a block that
actually had the cop station
on it and it was crazy around there
there was prostitutes
in front of the cop station it was just
it was it was crazy
but um uh you know i
uh grew up in a like i said uh you know
well i grew up
i was raised by a single mother
uh no father he was uh
he my mom kind of just bounced on him
she just disappeared on him
uh when i was about three because he was
on drugs as well he was on
coke and uh you know from what she said
he just used to come over eat up all the
food and uh he was just
pretty much useless and uh
and so she just shook him she just was
like well you know if you're gonna be
this kind of father
i can't you know it's just better that i
just disappear on you and she just shook
him
and didn't really think about how that
would have affected i i don't know now i
think about it and i'm just like
uh what about me like you know like what
would have did you ever even think about
how that would have affected me
but um so yeah so she shook him when i
was three i never even got to meet him
i mean of course back then but i don't
remember i
vaguely i vaguely remember like a it's
like a blur
to me you know his face i don't even i
don't even have a picture of him so i
really
i really don't even know what he looks
like you know so it's a
it's a trip but um throughout my
childhood
you know you know there was my mom's you
know uh
companions and uh you know ex-boyfriends
or whatever there was only one that
actually stood out and actually was
there
uh while i was you know a teenager or
whatever but
and uh he he actually was like more of
the father figure and
and really actually uh was significant
um you know they didn't work out but
eventually but it regardless that that
was actually the only
dude that i kind of uh wanted to kind of
be like him because he was a man like he
you know he worked hard he you know uh
a good example i guess a good uh someone
good to look up to or
or whatnot but regardless uh there was
really like no
somebody solid there throughout my
childhood so
i had the streets uh my friends
my friends were just who i would uh turn
to
uh i was i was my only child i mean i
have a sister
my mom said i have a sister on my
father's side i don't i don't know her
on my father's side but my sister i
don't even know her
in person i just met her over the phone
and uh
just communicated with her because she
is actually
in el salvador my mom salvadoria my dad
is dominican
but she was raised over there by my
grandmother
my grandmother passed away then my aunt
raised her so
uh so yeah i'm only child because i was
only here but
you know like my mom raised me here she
left my sister over there so she raised
me here
and pretty much a holy child so i was
bored a lot i was there was a lot of
boredom throughout my childhood so
i always wanted [ __ ] to do uh so i'd
just be on the street my mom
uh throughout my childhood like my mom
she tried to be strict but she couldn't
handle me i was a wild ass kid
um in front of her
i was i was a good kid so she turned her
back though i was
[ __ ] the horns would come out and it
was just you know
uh i was not who she thought i was never
never was who she thought i was you know
but she was so strict and she was so uh
she tried to be so strict
and she tried she would always whip my
ass you know that's that old school uh
salvadorian or hispanic way
nowadays you put your hands on your kid
and you're going to go to jail or
they're going to take your kids
but not back in the days back in the
days you get a good old-fashioned ass
whooping and that was just it you know
um
you know grandma used to just you know
wrap up a
[ __ ] extension cord and start
whooping our asses she would make us
kneel on rice uh she would make us kneel
on rice and hold up a chair if uh
if we'd [ __ ] up you know we'd be out
there terrorizing and breaking windows
and [ __ ] like that
um so
uh let's see so anyway uh i like i said
i grew up in a gang infested
neighborhood
eventually my friends that i grew up
with uh
we were actually very close my mom knows
all my friends we all grew up together
that was the gang that was the gang that
grew up there
the gang that actually grew up on my
block
that was all my friends my closest
friends uh
so it wasn't really like a i mean yeah
it was a it was
it was a gang thing but it was we were
friends we were not it wasn't like
i wasn't trying to fit in it was it was
actually who my friends were so
i just fell right into it and i was
raised in it so
i was raised in the area so so that it
was just a part of i mean you know
where i lived where i'm where i was from
or where i'm from
so uh
uh let's see uh so i started using drugs
at about
let's see i must have smoked some weed
when i was about 12
for the first time seventh grade walking
home from school
we started smoking beeties i don't know
if you know what bts are but
beatties are like these uh they were
like leaf wrapped cigarettes
and they used to come in a little tiny
box they did so that was the first thing
i ever like
i was like what the [ __ ] okay that was
like the first tobacco right
and then uh and then eventually we you
know we
started walking home from school and you
know as the weed the joints started
just getting passed around it was
seventh grade uh
you know i was actually a i was pretty
good i was pretty good at school
uh i just as soon as the weeds started
coming into to play and all that [ __ ] uh
then i started slacking on on the school
work i knew all the school work but i
just didn't do the [ __ ]
i was i was just lazy uh
you know just i just wanted to once
once i uh got the taste of uh mind
altering like i started
altering my mind that's when i uh that's
when i
i kind of i was like oh [ __ ] i i just
don't because i kind of wanted to forget
a lot of [ __ ]
uh whatever i lacked whatever i felt i
lacked i just wanted to forget
all that [ __ ] so i i just
wanted to alter my mind and forget a lot
of [ __ ]
so we came in and then drinking and then
[ __ ] by the time i was in eighth grade i
was just we
were partying it up like you know i was
you know
after uh we would ditch every friday i
don't think there was i don't think i
ever went to school
on a friday from from [ __ ]
eighth from seventh grade throughout all
junior high
and then i didn't really make it well i
didn't really make it to well i did make
it to high school tenth grade like half
of this
semester and then you know i i you know
i
was already i was already going to
juvenile hall and all that [ __ ] and um
uh so i i would you know get out
and go back to school but then i started
going to this probation school
and it was like part then i went to
camp and it was just like
in and out of jail uh started probably
at 14 was the first time i went to
juvenile hall so yeah the first time i
went
you know i didn't get into much trouble
because i was new to it and
you know at 14 i looked like i was about
10 because i've always been thin
uh first time i hit prison i was 18 and
i looked like i was about 15. um
that was quite a [ __ ] experience
it was some [ __ ] i i i uh
i got tried as an adult at the age of
17. as soon as i turned 18 they shot me
to the joint
uh i went i walked into uh you know i
remember
like if it was yesterday walking into to
to the prison yard and i was just like
what
the [ __ ] it was just like a it was like
a fear
but like uh
it was like a fear but at the same time
it was like a
like a i'm a man now type of feeling
um it's [ __ ] up the way
the way uh the way our
our i don't know the way our culture or
our
society or our community the way that i
was brought up the way
that the way that mind frame it just
[ __ ] blows my mind the way that i was
thinking
at that time i was just like wow [ __ ]
this but at the same time it's like [ __ ]
yeah
because uh ever since i was a kid
growing up with my friends
we kind of used to talk about that [ __ ]
like yeah you know
i probably in the in the joint for sure
i got to go do at least a couple terms
like
i need at least a few terms under my
belt like it was like a it was like a
[ __ ] goal you know it was like a goal
it was it was
it blows my mind how it was a goal to go
to prison
you know what i mean and surely enough i
ended up in that [ __ ] you know
for quite some time and uh and out of
prison
throughout all my 20s even up until my
30s
uh i'm 40 now i'm 40 years old and uh
uh i've been out for for a few years and
it's probably the longest time i've ever
been out you know i've been out five
five years now
five or six years yeah i have two kids i
have two kids i have i have a
i have a 16 year old son and uh
i don't really communicate with him much
because his mom is a
is she's very difficult you know and uh
uh it seems it seems like uh
uh it seems like you know her and i
didn't work out for for a lot of
uh we just didn't work out first of all
when we first got together it wasn't
really uh
it wasn't a love thing it was more of a
we kind of hooked up we were seeing each
other for three months
i went i got busted uh to go do a
violation she comes to the jail
and tells me i'm pregnant and i was only
seeing her
and i'm like okay she's like i'm
pregnant and i'm keeping this baby and
i'm like
okay then i guess we're gonna have to
try
to work to try to be together i guess
because you know we were just
seeing each other and so we tried but
eventually we just figured out that we
just weren't not compatible uh
and there was some cheating that you
know some just a lot of [ __ ] that
happened that just was not
uh it just [ __ ] everything up because
then there was a lot of
a lot of animosity between us and so
that created a distance
uh between like back then her only
threat was like
you're not with me you can't see your
son
so uh i kind of just stayed with her you
know
throughout her cheating uh i put up with
it because i just didn't want
to be away from my son and eventually
that's what ended up happening anyway
she i caught her i caught her cheating
and
red-handed and uh and then she was so
bitter that i wouldn't take her back
that
she she just sensed my son away from me
and just would make it difficult to see
him and then eventually that made me
kind of it just discouraged me so then i
kind of just
stopped trying to communicate as much
with him so
it created a huge distance between us
now it's been
wow it's actually i haven't seen him
since he was nine
and he's now 16. the last time i saw him
he was nine
ten nine no he was nine so
i have a i have i have a two-year-old
daughter as well
she's just she's that's
you know that's that's my world right
now
because i feel like i have another shot
at being a father and
it gives me a lot of hope and not only
that but she's crazy about me and she's
too and she's just
full of life and she's just so you know
happy
and she's a she's a girl so it's like
it's different you know having a girl
when i had
a little girl it just changed my it
changed a lot of [ __ ]
changed a lot of [ __ ] in my in my into
my brain
because uh because now i have i have to
raise a woman
and it changes everything it changes
everything because i
all the [ __ ] that i did in my life two
women
oh god it's just [ __ ] it's like oh my
god
i don't want her to ever go through no
[ __ ] like that so now i just gotta
kind of um try to i just have to protect
her and
just stay close to her my main goal is
to just become her best friend
you know and and try to be a good father
and uh
and just to be there you know be there
that's just that's just
the main thing you know because i wasn't
there for my son i just need to make
sure that i'm there for my daughter and
you know so as far as
uh family my family my family is a
it's a trip and i have a i don't have a
very big family
uh but it's all women my family is full
of women i only got
one uncle and like four cousins that are
three cousins that are males like four
three or four cousins that are males
and the rest is all women it's a bunch
of women and they're all
salvadorian because i was only raised by
the salvador inside of my family i
wasn't raised by the dominican side you
know my father's dominican i wasn't
raised by his family i was raised by
nothing but salvadorian
strong and these women these women are
crazy they're they're they're
they're they're strong character uh uh
very bold they're they're [ __ ]
straight out there
there's no gray it's like they're
they're crazy and they don't give a [ __ ]
and and they'll let you know
and so this is what i was raised by a
bunch of women
uh and then you know there was you know
my uncle
and then uh you know a bunch of a couple
of us
and there's only two of us that were
fuck-ups actually there was three two of
us
as males that were fuck-ups and uh the
rest the rest of the family is actually
not not so not so bad uh
you know my family's crazy though
because they don't even get along
between each other and [ __ ] like my
aunts
you know my aunts and my mom and it's
like they all go at it and it's just
uh chaos but there's really no drug use
in my [ __ ] family there's just really
not it's
like i said i think i started using and
all that [ __ ] just to forget
a lot of [ __ ] that that i felt inside me
but it really wasn't like this
just really it's not something that i
actually saw growing up or my family was
like all into drugs it wasn't like that
it wasn't like that with me
uh you know yeah my mom had
ex-boyfriends and
actually that's the first time i ever
saw uh somebody actually do
drugs in front of me i walked in on on
my mom's uh and actually that was the
dude that was actually the great father
figure type dude
and i actually walked in on a man and he
was [ __ ] doing a line
and as soon as i walked in he was just
like you know oh [ __ ] and
just wiped his nose and then he was he
was doing a big ass line and i was like
oh [ __ ] and i just kind of closed the
door
so then i kind of opened my eyes because
i was about what nine
and it kind of like opened my mind to
like what the [ __ ]
i've seen that somewhere and i i think i
might i might have heard or seen it on
tv
or something or whatever but and then
and then it kind of just like
you know uh opened my my mind to it and
then i started
asking about it and you know not him or
anything like that but i started
looking into [ __ ] and uh
okay i guess i was just looking for
something to i was looking
to to alter my mind i feel like i was
looking to alter my mind ever since i
was a kid you know
and uh yeah so i didn't really get into
heavy drugs until i was about
17. that's when i tried everything you
know at 17
17. because before that i used to sell
drugs uh
uh you know in the hood you know uh it
was like not not
it was it was frowned upon if you would
be on that heavy [ __ ] you know it was it
was cool if you smoked weed
and so yeah we used to smoke weed and
sell rock you know sell crack and then
uh
toddler hookers and all the i mean all
the pros all the prostitutes and all the
uh
uh you know all the dope fiends in the
hood and uh
it was frowned upon if we even [ __ ]
around with it so
so we wouldn't you know we would just uh
we would just
i think back then i think uh i was about
what 13 when i first started slanging
and for us it was more of a [ __ ]
my mom didn't want to but she couldn't
afford what i the [ __ ] that i wanted to
wear you know she
she couldn't afford the big ass clothes
she didn't want
to buy me the big ass clothes that i
that i wanted to wear the big baggy
clothes that she she was like i ain't
buying you that [ __ ] you figure it out
you know so
you know i just started slanging and
then
eventually she was like where the [ __ ]
you getting so much money and then i was
i just used to blame it on my ex
my little ex-girlfriend oh she bought it
for me she bought it for me she bought
it for me
where'd she get money or her dad gives
her money you know then it was just a
big old lives
uh and then one time she caught me
selling drugs to a hooker
i mean to a prostitute sorry she caught
me selling drugs to a prostitute started
screaming at me from the
from the second floor jess hey what the
[ __ ] are you doing but she thought i was
like
dealing with the prostitute like maybe
trying to
get something from her like you know
trying to buy some
sex or something but she didn't she
didn't really
know she was just like what the [ __ ] are
you doing and i was just like
nothing nothing and i just threw her off
and she i was like what she lives down
the street i know who she is and
she was like don't talk to her to them
they're hookers don't [ __ ] talk to
them and then
i was like oh okay my bad whatever she
thought i was like an innocent kid but
she didn't know i was a full-blown
[ __ ]
you know i had a gun i had it was like i
you know
she didn't know anything about any gun
until
uh you know they raided my pad when i
was you know a kid and then she broke
out a
shotgun and a gun and she was like what
the [ __ ] and then they told my mom you
know did you know your son is a gang
member
and dave she was like what and she just
was oblivious she did not know [ __ ]
uh because i i hit it good from her you
know what i'm saying like it was obvious
but my mom was real naive to [ __ ] like
that she's so old-fashioned she's she's
from a
you know country that it's a very
close-minded type [ __ ]
and uh but yeah i mean you know she just
didn't wanna i
i in a in a sense i just i i don't think
she wanted
to believe that i was an active gang
member she didn't she didn't want to
believe that [ __ ]
she thought my friends were just those
are his friends you know they'd all just
you know uh you know even though i would
tell her all the time oh yeah you know
so-and-so he got busted he's in jail
oh for what and then you know it was
just like a thing you know we were in
the hood so just these things were like
they happened she just never it never
dawned on her that
are you [ __ ] like like a gang
members like she never
you know oh yeah once his name got shot
and she oh yeah who shot him like why
like you know oh it's like you know my
mom was really naive to a lot of [ __ ]
because she's
straight from the country she's not you
know she wasn't raised here in london
uh but yeah now she's up on everything
she knows what's up now
you know because [ __ ] i mean after all
the [ __ ] i put it through it it went
through
um yeah so
so i yeah uh at about 16 17 i started uh
you know i started
started [ __ ] around with uh primos
you know mix the crack with with the
weed and
and uh because i used to sell
sell cracks so we used to uh we started
rolling primos and
tried that and that [ __ ] was like whoa
and then
you know i just kind of went on one with
that [ __ ] i really
i really went in with that and and and
did it did it hard
because uh that's actually how i ended
up catching that first case
uh uh you know we started doing
robberies and all kinds of [ __ ]
uh and then we really went in on the
whole gang banging like we really went
balls out it seems like it just [ __ ]
turned a switch just turned into
everything was like [ __ ] it and i don't
you know everything was to turn into
[ __ ] it and
i don't give a [ __ ] and uh my attitude
changed uh
i don't know a lot of [ __ ] changed
uh didn't really give a [ __ ] and then i
just turned into this mean [ __ ]
i don't know i feel like all the [ __ ]
that i i wanted to forget
like uh you know like i said before uh
there was a lot of [ __ ] that i just
wanted to forget so
so uh i was very angry
i was very angry growing up like as a
kid
as a kid i was like a sad kind of kid
but as soon as i turned into a teenager
that sadness turned into like anger and
then i was just violent i became violent
i was very violent kid i was fighting
all the [ __ ] time you know
i might have got my ass whooped so i got
my ass whooped so many times
because i would pick fights and get my
ass beat you know
eventually you know after so many ass
beatings you eventually kind of learn
how to fight and
then you know you think you're cool and
then you just start picking fights and
then you just start
fighting everybody and and then you know
you uh
growing up was violence uh for me but a
lot of violence
a lot of violence a lot of a lot of guns
and
drugs and and uh
meanwhile my mom's naive to a lot of
[ __ ]
didn't really know what was cracking
so let's see
started uh i went to prison i went to
prison
i went to prison huh [ __ ] i've been in
prison like five times man
i've been in prison five times in a few
terms uh four years three years two
years two years two years a lot of guns
i have four gun charges i mean they come
with other [ __ ] but
but i have a lot of guns in my in my in
my rap sheet uh
i felt like i always needed one you know
i felt like
a lot of homies that i got that got
smoked you know that got killed
and i felt like [ __ ] that i'd rather get
caught with one than without one you
know i'm saying so
so i always kept i always kept the gun
man i always kept the burner
always
just got kept getting caught with the
[ __ ] though
i went on a i went on a high speed i
went out two high-speed pursuits i was
on the news once
i got like 15 seconds of on the air
and uh i went on a high-speed pursuit
here in here in skid row
all through this [ __ ] just high
full
speed until finally i got caught in
traffic and jumped out the car
started running through the fire the
flower district
threw the gun in a big ass bucket of
water
finally they caught me and they still
found the clip so i still got
a year for possession of ammunition
because i had gun charges before that so
i ended up back in prison for a year and
a half or so
first time i went to prison man i i i
was only supposed to do
you know i got tried as an adult i was
only supposed to do 16 months with half
i turned that 16 months with half time
which was only supposed to be
nine months it turned out to be back
then
at nine months i turned into four years
three months
uh because i i started [ __ ] up
uh you know i just a lot of [ __ ] you
gotta do when you're in there that
it's inevitable you know it's like you
you know
you know they they uh it's just some
shit's just inevitable you know you
gotta you gotta roll with you gotta
go go with the flow uh you know
it's either you're a shark or a guppy
you know and i'll be damned if i'm a
guppy so you know
gotta do what you gotta do especially at
that age you know at that age it's like
you got to kind of prove yourself you
know you
you're brand new you're you're you know
you gotta you gotta
you gotta go hard so i did and then i
just ended up stuck there for quite a
while so
you know i got out and just went women
crazy
uh you know i got out at 20 i was out to
22 i think
i got up 22 march 4th
2002 i'll never forget that day i flew
home flew home from sacramento
you know they drove me four hours no
north i mean south
to sacramento flew home from sac
arrived in burbank uh jumped out the
plane
[ __ ] gone a minute uh i
didn't even know how to get home finally
it done until me like [ __ ] it i'll just
catch a cab went home
uh my mom wasn't home nobody was home
it's like uh
i went to go knock at the manager's door
it's a whole nother manager and then i
i don't know it was a trip it's
you know time time man this is uh
it's a most precious thing it's uh some
[ __ ] you can never get back and that's
why they take it from you you know
you lose you lose out on a lot of [ __ ]
you miss out on uh life you know people
die
while you're in there people people have
kids i got out and [ __ ] everybody had
kids
what the [ __ ] it's like everybody had
kids when i got out
everybody had kids and it was a trip man
people got married people had kids some
people
died uh other people just had some crazy
experiences it's just like you miss
out on a lot of [ __ ] you know i had my
aunt passed away while i was
you know my favorite aunt you know
passed away
while i was in there that [ __ ] [ __ ] me
up because then
uh and then on another term another one
of my aunts passed away you know and it
was like
it's [ __ ] up man you miss out on [ __ ]
that you know you you just you know
important significant things that you
know
uh so where are you today what's that
today where were you at today so today
uh i'm still [ __ ] up
but uh throughout the years man i still
uh
i don't know one thing i've always been
i've been blessed to be able to bounce
back
uh immediately like uh i get out of
prison and then i bounce back right away
i'm on my feet
you know i get a job and i'm on point
and then boom so
uh i actually managed to to put myself
through uh trade school it's
it wasn't trade school it was a i went i
became a
a union plumber and so through through
the union they sent you to school
so i made it up to what i think was
second year apprenticeship
but i got all the schooling and then i
still kept all the books
so then i kind of just rolled with the
whole plumbing thing and now
i'm you know a skilled plumber i'm i
know
i know how to re-pipe a whole house from
the ground up so uh
i've been doing it now for uh what since
i've been out
six years i've been doing plumbing and
and i'm pretty [ __ ] good at it so
that's what i do now i'm a plumber and
uh i just seem to just
uh it's like a it's like a self-destruct
man because i know that i can get
whatever the [ __ ] i want quickly
uh so it's like i i don't give a [ __ ]
sometimes
and i'll [ __ ] off a few thousand dollars
just because i know i can get it right
back uh
it's a [ __ ] up thing because it's uh
it's like a self-sabotage you know it's
a
it's it's just not cool man uh
but it's kind of it's it's like a it's
like a chip on my shoulder type [ __ ]
it's like a confidence that uh
i know i could get the [ __ ] you know
it's nothing and so i [ __ ] it off
you know it's insane it's [ __ ] weird
i don't even know
i don't know you know i've been a rehab
man i've been a rehab
a few times and that's where i learned a
lot of [ __ ] about myself that i didn't
know
that uh why i think the way i think and
you know
kind of got to define a lot of things
that you know about myself
um you know you go through therapy you
do all kinds of stuff in there that
teaches you about yourself you do a lot
of writing too so writing
about yourself teaches you
about yourself you know you you uh as
you write you kind of
you you go back to read it and you're
just like holy [ __ ]
you know it's like you're learning about
yourself and
and i never really tripped on that until
i went
i went to rehab you know i've been in
rehab [ __ ]
four times man and uh
i'm about to go back you know saying
sorry
uh yeah it's uh i mean you know i i
drink i smoke
primos and cocoa puffs and
cocaine and a little bit of garga
you know uh heroin that that is
uh every now and then i don't i don't
i'm not like though i don't slam or none
of that i
i snort it uh
but uh i've done it all though i've
smoked pcp i've
[ __ ] acid uh shrooms uh
you know coke speed meth [ __ ]
heroin you know
i mean there's probably only a couple
drugs i don't i don't think i've ever
tried ecstasy
i heard that's the [ __ ] but
but uh i mean you know um there's
probably only a few drugs that i haven't
that i haven't done but
for the most part uh it's like i don't
want no new habits i already
you know had my share of [ __ ] already
with the ones i have done
so now i'm i'm i'm like there's really
no solid
place you know that i could actually say
that i'm living there because
uh yeah my mom's place is always a place
that i can go to
but i don't like to be there i'm 40
years old so i don't
i don't my mom has a roommate and and
that means that i have to sleep in the
living room and i don't
i feel like i'm too [ __ ] old for that
so i just rather not be there and i'd
rather
not be there so i'll rent rooms and
[ __ ] be jumping around from hotel to
motel
uh airbnb whatever i i i just bounce
around from hotel motel
you know and i hustle and then i work
and so i'm
you and then know and then i'll and then
i'll
come [ __ ] off a week over here on skid
row you know what i'm saying
or or or or in a whole nother area
that's like skid row you know what i'm
saying and and you know
it's just it's just a f
you know and i've been coming around
this [ __ ] for quite some time
i've been i
first came to skid row when i was about
20 well yeah it was about i was about 22
first time i ever
first time i ever actually came here to
score dope i came with a bunch of my
friends
and we were 17.
all right that was a 97.
[ __ ] was way different back then over
here man [ __ ] was way
different this was this was crazier um
and then i didn't come back until you
know i got out of prison you know so i
came back when i was 22 but then i kind
of
still kind of came back every every now
and then but see i would just come score
and bounce i'll just leave
uh but see now recently these past six
years i kind of been over here
a lot not a lot like like to where i
live here but i'm here
a lot you know uh i come over here and i
and i
you know i i've i'll go i'll rent rooms
around this [ __ ] and just
you know and and post up and and and
slang to support my own
[ __ ] habit or not even slang just
i i go high hustle and and it's just
like
it's like there's so much [ __ ] that
that i can't even mention that i had to
do like i'm not saying like i don't do
no weird [ __ ]
uh but i do a lot of legal [ __ ] you know
and you know that's how we support our
habit around this [ __ ] you know
and uh we hit licks we do all kinds of
[ __ ] we we
you know it's just how it is man when
you're out there trying to chase that
[ __ ]
you know you pretty much do whatever the
[ __ ] needs to get done
you know to get that [ __ ] you know it's
[ __ ] up but
it is what it is that's just how it is
you know close it out
it was great you did a great job
you can close it out then i think we're
probably
i mean hey
i i just i know
that i'm not you know to say this ain't
how i'm gonna live the rest of my life
i'm 40 years old i'm
probably only going to live another 20
years considering
i have have had bad eating habits since
i was a kid all the drugs and [ __ ] i
probably don't have
a life expectancy past 65 or some [ __ ]
but i know that uh this ain't it for me
man this is
this is this is some this is [ __ ] up
you know and uh and i hope you know
i uh i hope i can open some eyes man
you know and maybe hopefully you know
plant some seeds and some brains out
there in the world to where uh people
know that this ain't this is
you know this is not how you want to
live you know the kids
you know times are different now you
know um
and uh i think that it's very important
to know how to deal with your stresses
uh whatever life brings your way you
have to know how i feel like you have to
figure out how you deal with your stress
whether it's exercise whether it's
sports whether it's
just you got to keep yourself busy
because boredom
it's like uh like my mom would say you
know uh
you know the boredom is it's like idle
time is the devil's playground
so if you ain't got [ __ ] to do find some
[ __ ] to do
get into something figure out what your
passion is do what the [ __ ] that is
because if you're bored a lot that means
you
you know you're not trying to figure out
what you love you know figure out what
you love to do
you know whatever you're passionate
about and do that
and figure out a way to get paid for
that [ __ ]
excellent thank you jesse thank you very
much
you